like stop being the people who are
stubborn about the how lose so you're
super stubborn on the why and flexible
in the how and most people don't have a
why most people don't have a why and
then are stuck on some irrelevant how if
you have a 10-year goal for yourself you
think this I was talking to my I met up
with my best friend Michael yep last
week and we got to catch up finally he
asked me a question he said what's your
what's your plan in five to ten years I
hate that question right like where do
you see yourself going and I still hate
that question yeah right okay and so I
was caught off guard okay the answer I
gave him is the is the one I came up on
the spot but I felt the most cuz I've
been asked this by a bunch of students
of mine and all the stuff and the answer
I gave him is I'm I am I am pursuing a
world where everybody feels like they
belong and they can have conversations
that they're too afraid to have because
they're worried about being judged okay
so why are you unhappy with that
it's the Martin Luther King I you know I
believe children of all colors but hey
you know hang out together and it just
it's just it's the whitey of a problem
with it
it's just over it's just the scope of it
is overwhelming it's never gonna happen
it's never gonna happen great so so why
is it overwhelming now it's never gonna
happen
but then what the hell do I say - why
would I even believe it if it's never
gonna happen that's ridiculous sorry
hold on it is ridiculous I know I know
look look I know okay so let me just
clarify this okay there's a part where
it's like you create such a massive
belief system okay that it it's eads you
throughout the weeks and the months
because your vision it's like I care
about people okay and my drive to serve
and care about people will never end
okay I will always want to do that and
so I get that sort of element of having
a big thing but it's more of Who I am
what I'm talking about is being an
influencer to the world and saying that
I want everybody to feel like they
belong and have the conversations that
they're too afraid to have because
they're worried about being judged and I
feel like they're enough in their skin
and so what does that look like does
that look like the TDS is in all the
major cities and like we're creating
that culture and I'm like I don't know
is that is that possible can that be
done maybe probably yeah yes it's doable
that's why it's a terrible question is
the house gonna change that if Mike
knows where he's gonna be in ten years
then he is thinking incredibly small to
think that you know what you can
accomplish in ten years right now that
you know the kind of person you're gonna
be in ten years means you were really
short-sighted you're selling yourself
short but where you are based on your
goals where were you ten years ago
you think you'd ever be doing this in
ten years
[Music]
someone else asked me there like about
TDS you know they're like are you gonna
be with TDS like what are you gonna do
after two days I'm like a family like
this is it
okay my person says I that's very
limiting like no I'm like I'm gonna be
seventy I'm gonna be doing this now that
we're talking right now I'm like is that
it like but even what is TDs can evolve
and change what is your role within TDS
do you want to be do you want to keep
teaching classes forever do you want to
have a franchise system do you want to
be a thought leader making virtual
reality videos and training people do
you want to be a speaker going around
the world but you know I guess I'm still
tied into the physical location but it
could be it might be having multiple
locations the thing is is there has to
be progress like having one location
still when you're 70 is not helping at
all
so that's it that's it like what is what
winners Mike want to be in 10 years
whatever his answer is is wrong like
throw that away immediately because even
if he goes and accomplishes it even if
he thinks that's ambitious right now
it's not ambitious it's not ambitious
it's weird are you saying that that
don't plan you can't know where you're
gonna be in 10 years how is that weird
were you gonna maintain I don't like but
having a vision for the business as an
entrepreneur of course a business vision
for the business I want the business to
be here in 10 years that's wrong too
how am I seeing am i am i understanding
it differently would like you have it
for the business and the goals right
like you have a vision for what you want
to build okay what a vision is the world
that you want to create that's never
gonna happen
so release yourself of the of the burden
and responsibility it's never gonna
happen you just getting up every day and
trying to do your your best I'm getting
so frustrated right now
you need to explain this better all I
think you should have is a is a lifetime
mission and then your short term goals
like what are you doing for the next
thing
five years ago when Steve my agent said
you should write a book said see if
you're stupid I don't want a book I
don't need a book is need a book to open
doors
I can open doors I'm on YouTube channel
the world of having to have a book to be
recognized is over
you'll need a book anymore I have two
books and I feel bad cuz people lock
themselves in my very first in turn
turned employee as guy who are hired
from whose Araki during like right after
the Iraq war okay yeah we have a Skype
call this guy has like the super sketchy
Skype profile see he's on this
internship program that come to Canada
for three months for six months I had to
vouch for him because I've always
couldn't get in this guy from it's a
rocky guy who I have one Skype phone
call with I have to admit like if he
does anything wrong it's on me cuz I'm
bringing him into the country okay okay
let's do it
something felt right right like that on
the guy great he comes he now has a
business around Google AdWords he's a
business on Google AdWords and I met him
recently and he's still doing Google
AdWords helping businesses with their
Google AdWords it's a it's an
increasingly losing game to be the
Google AdWords guy you shouldn't be in
that business anymore mine because of
Google AdWords is harder and harder to
to make money from no it shouldn't be
about Google AdWords it should be about
helping people use online advertising to
promote their business well now he
should be in the Facebook and Instagram
so what you're saying is when you make a
when you make a commitment into what
you're doing what how you're executing
things currently you lose you lose
yeah don't be all the greatest
entrepreneurs of all time are insanely
stubborn on the why you're stubborn
stubborn stubborn as anything on the why
this has to happen why we're doing this
doesn't change ever
but the how you flexible on
how you do it I don't care right now I'm
doing YouTube do I think in 10 years I'm
still gonna be doing YouTube I don't
know probably not we're gonna be doing
VR you're gonna see virtual reality Evan
coming in your face right
even now I'm spending more time on
Instagram than I ever did
yeah my do my lives for time a week
versus once on YouTube I like it better
I'm having I'm enjoying it maybe it
maybe I just dumped YouTube and go
all-in on Instagram like stop being the
people who are stubborn about the how
lose same thing like if you try to
photocopy yourself and have Christy do
it like this yeah you lose so you're
you're super stubborn on the why and
flexible on the how and most people
don't have a why most people don't have
a why and then they're stuck on some
irrelevant how so clementa what is what
is belong you mean you know the world
that you want to career I think I think
what you gave is a great answer like I'm
proud of you for that answer I thought
you would have given a really crappy
answer to be honest like something
you're not proud of like I want TDS to
be when I asked you before like I want
TDS and if I could I was like what do
you who cares but but don't worry about
that but but that's this is the thing
like the reason that answer came out was
out of my frustration that I thought I
wasn't good enough to give the answer oh
I thought it was a great aside of all
time what's Mike's answer piece of
garbage that's what his answer is Mike
if you're watching this your answers a
piece of garbage
don't say that wherever he thinks he's
gonna be in ten years is garbage
compared to where he could be compared
to where he could be what he could
because once you get stubborn on the how
you'll go get your how you'll make that
how happen but it's extremely small
compared to the how that you could have
had and that's the trap that successful
people fall into high achievers because
you go on you max out the how amazing
but you should be ten times that bit
that big you should be way off into a
different planet
but you got to stubborn on your hand so
you don't ultimately lose
you lose compared to what you could have
done but I remembered this clear
conversation where I asked you like
what's your vision and you said I wanna
help a billion entrepreneurs I think
that was your answer mm-hmm and I was
like but that's not what does that what
does that even mean mm-hmm my answer to
Michael was my understanding of what you
thought we're talking about here's the
thing it means whatever I want it to
mean about that don't don't don't don't
be a mystery wrapped no when they got
what it is kind of listening you know I
wouldn't even people ask me how do I
track a billion entrepreneur how do you
know when you've done it I don't want to
track it we're not tracking this this is
a lifetime never gonna happen goal
Lifetime Achievement Award the point is
that it focuses my projects on impacting
a lot of people why don't I do
one-on-one coaching a lot because I want
to help a billion people I want to touch
a lot of people in a small way instead
of five people in a major way yeah it's
what I want to do so when I say I want
to help a billion people great it gears
my actions why do I write a book because
I think is gonna get me closer to that
goal
why are filming this video it's gonna
get me closer to that goal and you might
say hey listen stop making videos that's
not the path you should be doing XYZ
like okay I'm open to it what's the path
tell me how to accomplish my goal but
the goal is never accomplishable
like you have built a house of belong
it's what we're building here it's a
house that belongs well people always
need a physical place to come to and
meet people and feel like they belong
they do then great then maybe we should
build an empire of houses that belongs
like me sure belong like every city
needs its own house it belongs Richard
belong the the circle if you have a
10-year goal for yourself you're
thinking small okay
thank you raise your standard Apple at
the core its core value is that we
believe that people with passion can
change not one drop of myself work
depends on Europe it's suppose to mean
if you want more of my thoughts on how
to beat the judgment of other people go
check out the video next to me I think
you're gonna enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
I think people are so worried about
other people's judgment that they don't
even try and that ends up being the
biggest failure of all